مدير جهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه
ان الجيش الروسي يصد هجوما مضادا لتجمع
قوه حلف شمال الاطلسي وليس هجوما للقوات
الاوكرانيه ان الهجوم المضاد يتم خلاله
استخدام الافراد العسكريين الاوكرانيين
كقوه بشريه فقط وكان نارشان قد اتهم امس
بريطانيا بمحاوله اقناع الدول الاوروبيه
بعدم جدوى التوصل الى تسويه سلميه في
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى انه ووفق المعلومات
التي حصلت عليها الاستخبارات الروسيه فان
لندن تسعى بكل ثقلها الى اقناع تلك الدول
بعدم جدوى اجراء اي وساطه بين موسكو على
الاقل طالما اوكرانيا قادره على ضرب روسيا
وفق تعبيره كما تام المسؤول الامني
الروسيه السلطات الاوكرانيه بالسعي لتحقيق
مكاسب شخصيه من خلال تسويق ما يطلق عليه
الروسوفوبيا بدل تحقيق نصر على روسيا وذلك
على حساب الشعب الاوكراني